up um we'll have uh aaron harrow tell us
about
uh super selection principle for
entanglement
great thanks for for having me um sorry
i couldn't i couldn't be there in person
this actually um so this is of course
the reunion workshop for the
um for the original workshop that i
wasn't at
but i'm going to tell you about
um a line of work that's basically
started with my earliest paper like the
beginning of my career was was thinking
about these topics
and which got a big boost from a
previous simon's reunion workshop
where i gave a talk about something and
mario zeggity gave a talk about
something
and then dorit arunov stood up and said
aren't you two talks basically the same
thing and
we emerged and had this fun paper
um so um yeah so i'll tell you about a
range of things
um many of which i'm thankful to um my
time at the simons institute for
for advancing um
and you know the story begins by by
thinking about the resource picture
of bipartite pure state entanglement um
so you know the usual story is alice and
bob
share some some pure entangled states
and
this this the space of all possible pure
entanglement cases may be quite
large but you can simplify the picture
with local unitary
if you assume that these are free they
can transform into this schmidt normal
form
and the conserved quantities are these
lambda i this should be coefficients
uh of course there's still many of these
so with with locc you can you can
further simplify things you get this
partial ordering based on the
the majorization relation you can
convert um
lambda to mu if mu sorry
if lambda is majorized by by mu if mu is
more concentrated than lambda that means
it's less entailed
um this too of course has many
inequivalent forms of entanglement
so things really simplify when you get
into the asymptotic regime
so if you have n copies of the state you
can approximately interconvert it to
n e epr pairs where e is the
the entropy of entanglement so
um this approximate interconversion was
an enormously successful idea
that i would say launched the entire
idea of resource theories more generally
in quantum information theory um this is
now a 25 year old paper due to
um benefit through
smolen and reuters so
um when
so i want to think about entanglement in
a in a slightly different way
i want to in this talk i want to focus
on the idea that it's that it's
conserved in particular that it's
conserved under local unitarians
and in physics we're you know we're
familiar with with conserved quantities
things like
charge um iso angular momentum
energy are are often conserved
and when you have a conservation law um
there what this means in terms of the
states is that the states split up into
subspaces
according to your conserved quantities
and your
operators either measurements or unitary
operators
um are constrained to respect this
partition
so for example this top thing might be
angular momentum
zero this might be angular momentum one
half the next one might be angular
momentum
one and if you have an operator that
preserves angular momentum
that carries no angular momentum of its
own then it will respect this
you know it'll be block diagonal
accordingly if you can even generalize
this a little bit if the operator
carries some angular momentum uh let's
say the operator has angular momentum
one
then that means it can change the
angular momentum of the state by one
they can take
four up to five or down to three but but
no further
and then it would still be sort of
nearly black diagonal
so so what about entanglement how can we
apply these principles to entanglements
is there a
um oh and i'm sorry these are called um
super selection sometimes these are
called selection or super selection
rules these
these rules saying that certain entries
in fact most of the entries have to be
zero
if they um you know couple one charge to
a different charge
um then often you know the symmetry of
the problem just forces them
to be zero so what is the what are the
analog for entanglement
so let me rewrite the schmidt
decomposition in a slightly different
way
um so let's
um let me write psi
as a superposition over a variable
number of epr pairs
so alice and bob each will have a label
k
that tells them how many epr pairs they
have then they share
k epr pairs that's what c2 means it
needs an epr pair
and then they're going to have n minus k
zero states really
just to pad things out and i'm gonna i'm
gonna stop writing these zeros because
it makes it kind of cumbersome you know
just imagine when i write up this stage
that they you know they have a
well-defined number of qubits and i'm
only going to write down some number of
each artifact
um and in general they can be a
different amount of weight to these
different
um values k of number of epr pairs and
will be given by some probability
distribution
so what does it mean that entanglement
is a conserved quantity
um under local unitary operations when
we do a local unitary
operation um k epr pairs
can only be maps to uh k epr pairs
and so you know maybe maybe in some
different basis but it's not going to
change
change the amount of entanglement so
this vector p sub k
should be approximately preserved by
local units
now i have to say approximate here
because
of course 100 epr pairs and the 101 epr
pairs
are not orthogonal back in the in the
physical picture of conserved quantities
if i have a state with electric charge
132
and another electric charge 133 these
are exactly what i thought
they have zero zero overlap no matter
how close the electric charges are
but here with epr pairs it's only
approximately true you have
you know substantial overlap between um
states of similar amounts of
entanglements
uh still though the uh the overlap
behave exponentially
as the difference in the animal
entanglement increases and so
still this may be a useful principle
um and i should there's one little
caveat which is what i've written is not
fully
general um you know not everything can
be written as a superposition of epr
pairs
however if i just modify this slightly
if i take this to be the entangled state
of uh schmidt rank 2 to the epsilon k
then these sorts of approximations can
give a
an epsilon approximation for for any
state
uh up to up to l u equivalents
so this and so intuitively this picture
is pretty reasonable but you know maybe
this one is a little bit more precise
um okay so what are the
okay so what does this mean in terms of
uh of allowed operations
um you know in what sense is the is the
entanglement actually conserved
um what this means is that if we have a
transformation use local unitaries
and q qubits of communication if this
were an exact conservation law
then that would mean if you if you went
q into the off diagonal
after two two steps off the diagonal you
would drop it exactly to zero
instead we get kind of a soft
conservation law
uh with two qubits of communication you
can increase the amount of entanglement
by q
so up to that much you know the matrix
elements could be one
and then beyond that they don't drop
immediately to zero but they go down
exponentially as you uh as you go
further from the bag
so the the matrix instead of looking
like this
you know exactly block diagonal form it
looks
uh sort of approximately block diagonal
so that's the first thing we would
expect in this
um in this approximate conservation
picture
the other thing we'd expect is um
you know we're you know we're used to
saying entertainment is a resource
and uh you know maximally entangled
states certainly sound like the most
useful thing there
but this points to a different type of
state uh here as i'm trying to
simply write a product state superposed
with a large maximally entangled state
states like this are um are unusual and
they seem hard to create
um and they you know they and they may
have uses that go beyond the uses of of
masculine tangled states
um so um
okay so with this so this is sort of the
intuition let's let's talk about how
let's talk about this a little bit more
concretely
in what sense are you saying valuable in
for those states
good so um we're going to see in a
minute how they are
hard to create from epr pairs um
and in other words they they require a
lot of communication to create some epr
pairs
so in this uh
in this original paradigm where the locc
means we're allowing free fossil
communication
i guess i should have said this but if
we if the classical communication is not
free if this is something that we have
to measure
then um
it may be difficult to create these
states and whenever something's
difficult to create
you it's potentially more useful
so if i have you know
if it's hard to make the state some epr
pairs then there's at least
one task they can do that epr pairs
can't which is create a state like this
right and then you know once you can do
one weird contrived task
better than epr pairs um and you require
a lot of communication to create it
maybe there are other tasks where they
can save on communication as well
that are you know more interesting or
you know that don't look like this um
where they can also save on
communication relative to charters
that make sense yeah
okay so um so
the first thing i want to consider is
what does the communication cost
to convert one state to another one so
um
we saw that there are constraints on
locc to convert one state to another one
but don't those don't measure how much
communication is required um
and the um
when you write it in this picture of
superpositions of different massively
entangled states
you can rephrase this as you have one
superposition over maximally entangled
states with distribution p
and another superposition with
distribution q and you'd like to map
one of these to another one and so the
the way you can do this is you can um
plot the histograms of p and q i mean i
guess
not really histograms just you're
plotting p and q as a function of k so
these are
the distributions over how much
entanglement and so let's say p
has you know a p here and here and here
and q has a peak here and is spread out
over this area
then the cost is going to be um what i
claim the cost is going to be roughly
the
l infinity earth mover distance
okay so what does that mean the earth
mover distance
um yeah maybe i won't define what it is
in general but the l
infinity earth mover distance is
basically saying
find a coupling between these two
distributions in other words for every
piece of mass of this distribution in p
move it to some point in q such that
you've
you know piled up all the dirt that dirt
was piled according to pee
move it so the dirt is piled according
to q and
the cost of this transformation um
you might ask what is the average
distance that dirt moves that would be
the l1 earth mover distance
you might ask what is the
square root of the average square
distance that would be the l2 earth
mover distance
what we care about is the l infinity
earth mover distance which is just
what is the furthest any piece of dirt
gets moved
so you know if we all want um
you know local tomatoes you know what's
the furthest fitter tomato happens
so in this picture what is the what is
the length of the longest arrow
now this is if you want to do it exactly
if you want to do it to epsilon error
the picture is basically the same except
you're allowed to
just throw away or create epsilon mass
wherever you like it
so it's basically the same kind of
elementary picture um
but with this uh you know epsilon
epsilon fuzz factor
um and so
when you think about the
this particular state here this has a
peak at zero entanglement and a peak at
n entanglement
and so these two are very highly
separated
this is going to have a high cost when
you start from any maximally entangled
state
when you look at this this picture here
maximally entangled states just have a
peak at one point
and so if you want to move it to two
things that are and distance and apart
you're going to need communication cost
n over two so that's why
these spread out states are always going
to cost um
n over two you know a cost that um
we'll have a large communication cost
per pair so
the lower bound i'm going to give you a
slightly
stronger argument to the lower bound in
a minute the upper bound
uh i hope you can kind of intuitively
see why it's true
which is that for every part of the
superposition you can do this mapping
with the appropriate amount of
communication so once you have this kind
of mapping
what you're doing is in one branch of
the wave function
you're moving 100 cubits to 110 sorry
100
epr pairs to 110 epr so that takes
communication costs 10.
in another part you're throwing away in
things you're going let's say from 60
down to 50
and again that costs 10 communication
and there's it's a little bit tricky
because in some branches you need to use
more communication than other branches
but uh you can get it to work out so
that you just take the maximum
of any of them in some branches you use
communication without creating or
destroying any entanglement
and other branches you create a lot and
other branches you destroy a lot
but as long as uh the total amount of
communication you use
corresponds to the earth mover distance
then then things will be okay
um
why do you need communication can't you
just like measure the epr pairs and
just like remove ten ebits that way
um great so um
yeah so yeah there's an important caveat
to what i'm saying so
what i'm talking about is the unitary
the cost of doing this in a unitary way
um now
um i actually i couldn't hear was that
henry you asked the question
yeah yeah so right as henry's question
was you know if i want to go from
100 epr pairs to 50 epr pairs there's no
communication cost i can just throw away
pr um and
um in general if i have
you know if alice and bob have two
states um
you know they have a state an a1 b1 and
another state an a2 b2
they can just throw away the state on
a2b2 at at no cost
um and so
when i say this is the communication
cost what i mean
is um if you don't want to throw
anything away
basically um if you do want to throw
something away
the thing you throw away has better be
disentangled with what you keep
otherwise you're going to incur a lot of
noise um
and so there's some limited examples
where you can throw things away
um and in those cases
um basically p
has to be written as a um
you know a convolution of two
distributions
right so if you have if you if you
combine two states
then what happens to the distribution p
is
it um they get combined via convolution
and so if you can you know there's some
cases where you just throw away a
subsystem
and and and still get an approximately
pure state um
but yeah but then apart from that then
the the unitary part of the
transformation has to look like this
okay so that is so this is the upper
bound
you know showing that it's possible
for the lower bound um
let me give you just sort of a
i'll give you an incomplete argument for
the for the lower bound
um but i think that one that gives you
gives you a sense of why it should be
true hopefully which is
suppose this is my state uh so i've put
in schmidt normal form
and i've sorted the schmidt values
um and i'd like to start from many epr
parents and map to this state
then when you put it into this language
the earth mover distance is given by the
log of the top schmidt value lambda 1
times the schmidt rank r um divided by
2.
so i'll call this the entanglement
spread of psy in the
um in this picture of uh
where we have a superposition of epr
pairs this is the the approximate width
of that distribution
um and the the reason why this
is a lower bound is every time you tran
if you start from a bunch of epr pairs
then this quantity is initially
zero because if you have many many epr
pairs
the top schmidt value is just one over
the schmidt
one over r um so delta is initially zero
and then every time you transmit a qubit
the schmidt rank
can go up by at most a factor of two and
lambda one can go down
um or up by by most a factor of two
um and so this this delta starts at one
it increases by at most one per cubic
cent
and so it's just a simply a conserved
quantity and
you can you can do approximate versions
of this as well that gives you you know
that behaves more or less how you'd
expect
and if you want to use this picture
where you have a superposition of
different number of dpr pairs
with a distribution p then the spread
here is is the width of the support of
this distribution
um so going back to this example if you
have
uh a pure state superposed with a
massively entangled state
then the um r is roughly two to the n
lambda one is about a half um
and so creating this this product is
about two to the n
so creating requires nearly n over two
cubics of communities
um so um
which which roughly matches the bound if
you just start from n over two epr pairs
and in one branch of the wave function
you boost this up to n and the other
branch you unitarily drop it down to
zero epr
so we have a lower bound that roughly
matches the upper bound
and um the
the general lower bound um
uses similar ideas but it's um yeah
this is in my paper with with matt
fudron i i won't present it now but
hopefully this gives you the
um the idea of why such a thing
is plausible so
entanglement okay so what have we done
so far we said that entanglement spread
characterizes the um the cost of
preparing
a state it's a upper and lower bound
on the cost of preparing the state from
from epr pairs
now i claim it's also an upper and lower
bound
on the cost of checking whether you have
a state
so suppose i'd like to do this two
outcome measurement i want to see do i
have the state psi
or identity minus or you know or not
right the orthogonal complement
the unitary version of this is i want to
perform a reflection about the state's
sign
um and these are
you know in general these are roughly
equivalent tasks and i claim the
communication cost
is going to scale with the um
the spread of psi plus there's a small
um
because the protocols we have for this
are approximate there might be a small
dependence on the error
um but it goes like log one over epsilon
independent of the total dimension or
or even any other features of the state
um and
along the lines of entertainment spread
being the valuable resource
free epr pairs do not change this at all
they don't improve the communication
cost of this task at all
um but other other states can other
states can
um you know bring it down to order log
more reps a lot if you if you have a
general um
if you're allowed the assistance of
other states other than epr pairs
so containment spread in other words
characterizes both the the cost to
prepare a state from egr pairs but also
the cost to test it
um any
any questions so far
okay so let me give you the the idea of
the lower bound here
um and again for the lower bound i'll
illustrate it just for this particular
state
um but the idea is is pretty similar for
a general state so suppose i i
could test whether i have n 0 1 tensor n
plus um c2 tensor n
or the entire orthogonal subspace
one easier task is to say well suppose
i'm just promised
i'm given the state with either the plus
or the minus superposition
and um
yeah so anurag is asking is
about the expander-based test for epr
states um
and uh for those of you who don't know
what he's talking about
we're going to uh i'll come back to this
in a minute basically but
for now the answer is it's going to use
this result as a subject um
you could say or and or as general and
it's generalized
okay so um suppose
yeah suppose my my task is the easier
one i just want to distinguish these two
states
so i'm given a superposition of zero one
plus
and epr pairs you know with product
state plus and the epr pairs or
product state minus and hdr pairs how
can i tell those apart
now if i use a lot of communication you
know bob could just send over
all of his qubits and then alice can
make the test right but how can they
how can they do this with a small amount
of communication
and if you look at this task of
distinguishing the two
distinguishing them is roughly
equivalent to putting a phase on one of
them
so imagine doing a sigma z gate in this
basis
right phase of one from one of the
states minus one for the other state
doing that is equivalent to doing a
sigma x
in the conjugate basis and what is the
conjugated basis
it's the product state and the maximally
entangled state
so being able to do a phase here is
completely equivalent
to be able to unitarily split swap these
two
so to take a product state and map it to
a maximum tangled state
and take a maximum tangled state and map
it to a product state
and what's interesting about this is
that this
if you're going to do it unitarily it's
hard to do even with epr assistance
so if i have a million epr pairs and i
want to map it to a million
plus 100 epr pairs i still need a
hundred cubits of communication
the fact that i have a million epr pairs
sitting around doesn't tell me
um and uh
and here it's crucial that the the
method of doing it is unitary so if i'm
going to use
some sort of entanglement assistance i
need to be able to return it
in an impact for um
and on the other hand
you know why can why can other states
help um
well first of all there's a state called
an embezzling state
due to van damme and hayden and the
embezzling state is remarkable in that
if you have an
entanglement embezzling state and local
unitaries
you can use that to approximately create
any entangled state
so it's sort of a universal
communication free
state state creator and then
one particular state that would be very
helpful if i want to do this task
is to have many copies of psi in
particular
suppose i have k minus 1 copies of psi
and then i would have one additional
state and i want to know is this psi
or orthogonal to it if it's psi then
altogether i have k copies of size if
it's orthogonal
then i have k copies of psi and then
some other state which i'll call side
perk
and it turns out these two cases can be
distinguished without knowing what psi
is using order log k cubes of
communication
and the reason is this state lives in
the symmetric subspace and so it's
invariant under cyclic permutation
and this thing changes a lot under
cyclic permutation and it only takes
log k qubits to specify a cyclic
permutation of k
objects so epr pairs
apr systems is really very different
than other kinds of issues
okay so that is the lower bound
what about the upper bound for the upper
bound let me specialize to the case of
epr test so suppose that alice and bob
share the state psi
and they want to know on the previous
slide
so so the state that you uh
uh the the helper state was a function
of the state that you were trying to
distinguish here what do you you know
what have you asked
uh instead of epr payers if you had a
helper state but it was
independent of the of this right
can it help at all yes that's an
embezzling state
um okay all right yeah hi
um by the way if you want a good open
problem uh
suppose you have a subspace you want to
distinguish a subspace pi
you want to measure pi versus identity
minus pi
um and you're allowed a helper state
how now and let's say that the rank of
of the projector is
r now we know that if
if pi is the symmetric subspace then
this is the swap operator and of course
the communication cost of that is going
to go like
like log r so log r is a lower bound
but by repeating this protocol with our
different helper states
the best upper bound i can get is order
r so
you know i believe there's a helper
state that should be able to get it down
to logar but i haven't been able to find
one
um okay so let me talk about the upper
bound
if psi is in a massively entangled state
the spread is zero so this says you
should be able to test if you have a
massively entangled state
with an amount of communication that is
independent of the size of the state
this just depends on the precision
so let's work out how that goes let's
suppose the state is an
n dimensional massively entangled state
alice and bob share psi and they want to
know
if they indeed have the maximum tangled
state
so one thing they can do is they say
well
look if it's maximally entangled it
should be invariant
under u tensor u star so if they have a
little control register let's say
dimension t then alice can use that to
do a controlled ui
and bob can use it to do a controlled ui
star
the true massively entangled state is
going to be invariant under all of those
so the control register will stay
exactly the same and so if bob
if alice starts at the control register
she applies you to buy
then she sends it over to bob using log
t qubits then bob
applies ui star and then checks whether
the control register is unchanged
if it's if they have if they share a
maximum tangled state
then yes the control register will be
unchanged
however if it's not a massively
entangled state
maybe these u's will take it all over
the place each one to something nearly
orthogonal
this will become very entangled these
two registers will become very entangled
and bob's measurement will probably
yield that it's
you know that's not in the original
state that that is the intuition
so c c is the unique state invariant
under u tensor u star
um and indeed this is the case
if they transmit if they want error
lambda they can trans
they need to transmit order log one over
lambda cubits
um and i think i want to just not
go into too much of the details here um
basically uh the subnormalized output
state
given acceptance is this one which is
you know one over t
sum over u i tends or ui star applied to
psi
and the acceptance probability is this
brass eye m dagger m
psi and so the key claim to the validity
of the protocol
is that this m operator this thing right
here is
a good approx approximate the projector
onto the maximally entangled state
up to some precision lambda okay so
so the error of the protocol will depend
on what this lambda is
and it turns out that this is basically
equivalent to
being a quantum expander so we say that
a collection of unitaries is a quantum
expander
if for any traceless operator x
averaging over these unitaries um
shrinks x in probinus norm it shrinks it
by a factor of lambda
and that's analogous to a classical t
regular expander graph which you can
view as a collection of permutations
that if you apply them to any vector
that adds up to zero it'll shrink the
two norm of that vector by a factor of
lambda
and um
here we know that random unitaries are
good expanders just like random graphs
random users are good quantum expanders
just like random graphs
are good uh you know classical expanders
and crucial the crucial thing about
expanders is that the
expansion coefficient just depends on
the degree
it does not depend on the size of the
graph the same thing is true
for quantum expanders this lambda
parameter depends on the number of
unitaries
does not depend on the dimension n
so um what this means is that the
communication you need is log one over
epsilon
and so to return to this theorem we have
an
order log one over epsilon upper bound
um
to to do this for the special case of
testing if you have a particular
maximally entangled state
but then this can extend to any other
state because we know
if you have any other state you can map
it to some maximally entangled state
using an amount of communication given
by the entanglement spread
of that state so for any state psi you
can map it to maximally entangled
test whether you're maximally entangled
and then map back
and the communication cost of that is
going to go like the entanglement spread
of the state
plus this order log one over x
and so this is the um
the the upper bound that matches our
lower bound for
for doing this uh this state testing so
now we've seen that entanglement spread
characterizes the
cost repair estate as well as the cost
to
test whether you have it
um okay so
this is really i would say just like the
basics of entanglement spread
so um you know these are kind of
like very you know
low level sub routines right so what is
what is sort of
an operational task that is interesting
that we want to use this for
um and i'm probably going a little too
slowly so i
probably don't have time to should
probably skip a few topics
um so let me skip um
yeah one thing we use this for a long
time ago with the quantum reverse
shannon theorem i'm going to skip all
that
um let me talk about arial laws
and communication complexity
so um one topic
where um you know everyone who hangs out
at berkeley
and does quantum information knows about
all the exciting
um progress in the local hamiltonian
problem that's come out here
uh and one of the
central one one big insight is that if
your hamiltonian is local
then the ground state should and the
energy gapped there's a gap between the
bottom two eigenvalues the ground state
should inherit the locale
and there are many versions of this so
if the bounce state is gapped
then the i'm sorry the hamiltonian gaps
then the ground state should
have correlation decay um and
also should have an area law and also
should have an mps description and all
those are sort of different ways of
saying that
it keeps the locality
and the
what the area lost conjecture says is
that the entanglement of a sub-region
should scale like the size of the
perimeter of that region
and more precisely if you have a bunch
of edges going from
inside the region to outside then you
should add up the dimensions of all the
particles along the edges
and and that should be a measure of the
of the you know
basically the perimeter of that region
so one thing that came out of this
simon's
uh reunion workshop that i went to
previously was this paper where we
uh we found a counter example to that
area lost conjecture that we found a
very simple
system with four particles one of
dimensions two of them of dimension n
and then two q twists in the middle and
if you if you
put this box around the left two
particles
then you find that the the gap is order
one the
boundary is order one and yet the
entanglement is near maximus log n
and if you want to do it just with
qubits there's kind of a cubit version
as well
and so what this suggests
is that you know maybe the area lost
conjecture
um you know you need to really think
more about the perimeter like
about the boundary because
maybe the the amount of entanglement
shouldn't depend just on the number of
edges that you cut
but because we have this exponentially
decaying correlations
we should allow contributions of
entanglement from things near the
the boundary as well so a revised area
lost conjecture would be
that the entanglement is you know for if
you have this
this red cut then you get full
contributions from stuff right next to
the cut
then like a little bit lower
contribution from stuff further away and
as you get further away you get
exponentially decaying contributions
um so that is a reasonable conjecture
and
so and you could say like the exact
aerial conjecture that the
the entanglement just comes from the
edges that you cut that was
unreasonable that was like too much to
ask so
us falsifying it you know we were
falsifying an unreasonable version of
the conjecture
however this exact area law where you
get
a contribution to the entanglement just
from the bonds that are cut
turns out to be true for entanglement
spread so it turns out to be true that
um the entanglement spread of the ground
state
is upper bounded by the really the exact
edges that are cut divided by the gap um
and actually another result which i
won't have time to present is if you
allow this fuzzy version where you you
spread out near the
if you look at nearby edges then the
spread is actually bounded by the square
root of that
um and i should mention that an exact
area law was also known
for the um for the thermal area law so
if you look at
thermal state and you look not at their
entropy
that's large but their mutual
information it turns out that obeys a
similar bout
so um yeah so what is the proof here it
really follows quickly from the
the statements i gave before so first we
argue that
alice and bob can estimate the energy of
a state to error epsilon
um sorry this should be delta a
over epsilon not delta a over gap sorry
um
using delta a over epsilon quadratic
communication
and the proof is to use phase estimation
right so if you want to estimate the
energy of something you should do e to
the minus i h
t for some superposition of different
t's
and if you write t as
h a plus h b plus a boundary term
then you really want them to only pay
the communication cost
of the boundary term and this is
achieved by this beautiful
hamiltonian simulation paper due of
guanghaolo and nathan weeby
um and the communication cost that
results
just scales like the size of the
perimeter divided by by epsilon
and so what this means is that if you
want to implement a
a reflection about the ground state
with error given by the um
um by the by the special gap
then the um then the cost goes like the
like the perimeter divided by by the gap
um
and and we know on the other hand that
to implement this reflection the cost
should be at least the entanglement
spread
of the ground switch and so this proves
that the entertainment spread cannot be
that large
so these exotic states like
superposition of product state and and
massively entangled states
uh can't arise as as ground states of
local hamilton
okay and so the last um thing i want to
talk about
i think i have like two or three minutes
left right um
is uh you know i said these are
potentially valuable in communication
complexity
um so by this i mean alice and bob give
some string they want to compute some
joint function
and they're allowed to you know either
communicate one way or two way
we know that shared randomness can only
help a limited amount
uh if you have a giant ship strings you
can de-randomize them by something
called newman's theorem
and just use a subset of those strings
entanglement does seem to help but the
only way we've used it to help is with
teleportation in other words taking
platform communication and turning into
quantum
we don't know if you know vastly larger
amounts of epr pairs would help
and you might wonder whether other kinds
of entangled states like embezzling
states can save even more communication
but matt kudron and i showed that the
general entanglement cannot really help
and the argument is is quite simple
suppose you have
um you know this is your starting state
this is the most general possible thing
right where you have superposition of
different numbers of epr pairs
and your protocol only uses two qubits
of communication
then the acceptance probability
will depend on your state as follows you
know your
your these uh the amplitudes of your
state will be sandwiched by your
protocol
and your protocol has these decaying
off-diagonal terms
so once you get far off the diagonal
these things are going to be mostly zero
and so it's not going to be sensitive to
superpositions between
very different amounts of entanglement
so if you were to feed in for example
the state
of product state plus a gazillion epr
pairs
you could have used product state minus
a gazillion ecr pairs and the protocol
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
and so then you also could have used the
mixture and so
that can be done just with epr pairs and
so you never need
to have a superposition of large amounts
of entanglement you never need to have a
lot of spread
the most spread you need is going to go
like i guess they were poly this should
have been big o of q over epsilon
uh and so large amounts of insulin
spread don't help
now for this um now
what this relies on is that you can at
least prepare
you can at least communicate between
alice and bob if you're in the
simultaneous message passing model or
like a bell testing model then
um the entertainment spread does help
so um and and this was there's one paper
due to regula that does this and another
uh i think due to toner and vayner that
show this for
like the bell testing scenario
okay so um so for these two applications
the big question is does entanglement
help in communication complexion
for area law we want to do ground state
satisfy an area
and what i can argue using this analysis
of containment spread
is that for communication complexity you
know do very large entangled needs help
well you can at least reduce the problem
to epr pair and then
for uh the area lock question we'd like
to know you know
do entangled states have a ton of
entanglement well we can at least assume
this entanglement
is of an epr-like form and so
i hope that this represents progress on
these questions you know whether they'll
lead to their ultimate resolution
remains to be seen but they arguably
move it into a
simpler form where instead of
considering arbitrary states we can just
consider nearly maxillary entanglements
and uh yeah as i've mentioned this this
work has
has been an on and off part of my career
since the beginning
i began with this root end lower balance
entertainment dilution
then with debbie lung did a state
testing
uh lower bound um review paper of it
and then used it for the quan reverse
shannon theorem
um then did this paper on the at the
reunion workshop where we did the cheap
epr testing
and the example to the the area law with
matt kudron
we showed the earth mover distance found
and
showed that it doesn't help with
communication complexity and then
finally with with anu raganshu and meiji
silvanthar
we gave this uh entanglement spread area
lock so it's been fun to work at it i
want to thank all of
my co-authored for the many years of of
fun and productive collaborations
um thanks to simon compute for for
hosting it's been super fun each time
and
and thank you much for inviting me this
okay and thank you for your attention
one short question uh if there any
was there a more precise statement about
um you know the area law
being able to restrict to epr like uh
states um
the more precise okay so the the
the statement is
the ground state has
entanglement spread you know the
entanglement the point is if the
containment spread is low
then the ground state is epr white okay
right
so we give two upper bounds our paper
gives two upper bounds
on the entanglement spread of the ground
state the first
one is based on the one i presented
where it's exactly the number of edges
that are cut
divided by the gap um and the second one
says if you're willing to consider
edges within an order one neighborhood
of the cut then you actually can get
square
root of that square root of the number
of edges but both of them are
are upper bound on the approximate
entanglement spread
of the ground state great
thanks that was a great talk thank you
let's thank aaron again
[Applause]
so next up